he's Greg Olson of the Carolina Panthers
their tight end on a bye week and during
his bye week he's going to broadcast a
football game Arizona against the Giants
and that'll be interesting we were just
talking prior to a coming back on the
show how much access you get as a player
who's currently playing in the NFL would
you be comfortable walking around the
Giants practice no I mean that's the one
thing even when we did it two years ago
and everyone made such a big deal about
whether I should have been having access
and done the game I never in a million
years even wanted to go to any of the
practices I don't go to the production
meetings I don't go to the stadium the
practice facility watch practice I won't
do any of that I'll do all my prep on
the back in the background get some of
the notes get some of the transcripts
from the media days and stuff but uh
outside of that I don't have any access
to any anybody over there now you toyed
with this a couple of years ago and I
think at the time we talked about making
that transition of when do you make that
transition you've obviously played
through injuries you've had a long
storied career but at what point do you
say do I get out early or do it you know
if a good job opportunity comes along
like Jason Witten had Monday Night
Football
now he wasn't ready for it but he did
get that opportunity I understand those
jobs don't come along Tiki Barber did
this as well have you talked to your
wife about that scenario of is there a
job and when do I take that job and then
quit playing football yeah I think
that's that's really the key I think
first and foremost if you're on the
fence at all about playing you probably
shouldn't play in order to continue to
play and continue to play at a high
level you got to be all-in and open to
this point for the most part I had been
I've had some injury issues and anytime
you're injured and on the Shelf you ask
yourself do I want to continue to rehab
do I want to continue to go through this
now third year in a row you know and and
the answer was yes I had some some
things that I still wanted to accomplish
personally collectively as a team I
thought we'd have a good team but to
your point the last couple years we did
have some different TV offers and
different TV opportunities come along
but you know they weren't the right
opportunities it wasn't it wasn't
something that I just couldn't turn down
because it might never come again to
your point about about Jason and Monday
Night Football you know that's one of
those jobs that if that's put in front
of you even if you think you
want to play you have to at least think
it through right you gotta at least give
that some thought because you might
never have that opportunity given to you
again and there's just so many things to
balance now with having kids and your
family and what you want to do
post-career
it's not an easy decision that's for
sure
but if you had one of those days where
you come home from practice and you just
say I don't want to do it anymore
you know this year not last year yeah
the previous two seasons for sure there
were days where I would come home and
say I can't continue to play like this
my foot is killing me I can't run I'm a
shell of what I used to be able to do on
game day you know I'm out there trying
to get everybody else open but which is
great but I can't run I can't cut the
way I'm accustomed to you know for 10
years never missing a game and now it
seems like I play half the season every
year and you know a lot of that is just
kind of feeling sorry for yourself and
kind of a pity party okay but what's
your wife saying you know my wife is
super supportive she she says if you
want to play we're all in right if your
family's not all in playing in the NFL
can be a nightmare but she's been all in
since college she understands that she's
we've been with each other for a long
time she's been through it all with me
but um I don't know your kids are young
enough
well old enough I should say yeah watch
dad play which is cool right so I'm part
of why it's really fun to be one of the
older guys and be the oldest guy on the
team you know I got guys on the team
that were my kids age when I first
entered the league and it's just kind of
a weird thing to think that my kids that
these guys would still be in the league
when my eight year old is old you know
is is their age but um are they alike
they'd love it
jerseys of other players on other teams
not on other teams like not on motors
like my team they they don't love
wearing dad Jersey like when they were
kids when they were all little they're
close in age when they were you know
three and four they would come to the
games always in my jersey and now they
wear my jersey but it's kind of like
pulling teeth they want to wear
McCaffrey and and who can cam and you
know they they have a lot of guys and
then if they think dad's feeling sorry
for himself to look dad but you're still
our favorite you know so they they know
how to my daughter though she's all in
on dad
she is 100 percent dad but um she gets a
little worked up when she sees Luke and
those guys so i yeah
you know it starts young but it's fun
for them to experience the game through
you know Mead now still playing and then
being older and bringing my boys to the
locker room and bringing him in the
locker room after the game and my oldest
son's in a fantasy football league with
his baseball buddies and I find myself
on Thursday afternoons after practice
like checking his fantasy lineup making
sure he doesn't have a guy playing in
the Thursday night game and Here I am
like for all these years hating fantasy
football because people would kill you
if you had zero catches and now I'm like
that guy cheering on my my kids fantasy
team so it's it's a whole different
experience but it's a lot of fun how
many times have you looked at what Kim
wears to a game I've seen every outfit
he's warrant for nine years but but but
have you ever said I think that's too
much yeah and does he have a winning
outfit in a losing em
he's got one outfit he is he is
committed to that outfit win lose draw
great game bad game he is committed to
what he wears to the locker room Mac you
gotta have a losing outfit though great
he's committed he's all-in and I give
him a lot of credit and he is all-in
he's not gonna apologize for it he's not
on he's very comfortable in his own skin
he is not concerned with outside
criticism it does not change and I give
him a lot of credit because I to be
honest I don't know if I have that much
self-confidence that I would even or
this scarf over his head every day not
just for the press car he wears every
day when he is the most when he gets
into a routine he is super super
consistent every day 6:00 a.m. meaning
doesn't matter what it is he's the same
guy every day
it's pretty remarkable is it guaranteed
that he gets his job back and I think
the biggest thing right now is we got to
just get him back healthy right we gotta
get him back to the lane let me put you
to the test you're not a player you're
an analyst covering the Carolina
Panthers can you could you do that I
just think it's hard right now to make
that decision without knowing what the
timetable of CAM being back let's say
they're both healthy Kyle Allen and
camera both healthy I think when cam
comes back and he starts practicing and
he starts working our way
and Ron and them have a tough decision
right I think that's we all understand
the elephant in the room we all
understand the reality kam has been very
special for this organization he's been
special for a lot of guys myself
included and I've been on the record a
million times to say that he has
elevated a lot of guys careers over the
years and he's done a lot for this
organization and when he's when he's
healthy and he's Cam Newton he's been
one of the most transcending players to
play the position in the last ten years
but when he's not himself
and he understood when he was in himself
he doesn't have that impact that he's
accustomed to having in those first two
games were a direct result of him not
being able to run not being his him
himself on the field and it meant it had
an effect on everybody and I think for
him to have that self-awareness and
realize for me to be the best I can be
for this team I need to be the best for
myself first I give him a lot of credit
cuz a lot of other guys would have said
no this is my job I'm not giving it up
you're gonna get me how you get me and
he didn't and I give him a lot of credit
for that and when that time comes that
he's healthy and he's back out there
that's Ron and them have that's why they
all make the big bucks do you got a Luke
Kuechly story man Luke Kuechly is one of
the most I always say like if I I have
two boys and I always I always joke like
I got to find out like what his mom did
because I want like if I want if you
want your kid to grow up like someone
you wanted to grow up like Luke Kuechly
and I got two boys and if you told me
they could be Luke Kuechly in 20 years I
would sign up today just great guy the
most he is like the ultimate giver the
ultimate giver I mean doesn't matter if
he's going to get a water bottle he'll
bring 50 water bottles for everybody
like he's just he is that guy and then
obviously he's an unbelievable player so
he's just a special guy he's a great
friend of mine but he is just a unique
like for instance we every year we go on
like a like a camping trip it's the OH
line tight end and Luke Kuechly camping
trip and we all so me him and a former
teammate Ryan Cleo we would all share a
tent like a big big tent but we would
joke that we would bring Luke because he
would set the tent up bring the tent by
the tent
make sure it's on the perfect you know
down he had this whole thing about it
has to be on
down slope so our heads or above our
feet ties all your fly lines make sure
your fishing poles I mean he he's like
the ultimate like buddy he's he is it's
hard to describe but he is a he is a
great dude did you hear the miles
Garrard story I did where he could he
gets punched by a fan she tried being on
offense where he did plays fantasy
football you want to see you want to see
fans I had zero catches last week I
think people on Twitter were trying to
blow my house up why I mean have you had
any any confrontations like the worst
confrontation you ever had with the fam
face to face yeah I've never had like a
violent confrontation thankfully like he
apparently happened with him and if
you're gonna pick a guy alright why
don't you pick that guy we guys enormous
I know I don't want to hit him you know
he's um he's a big dude who's the--who's
the last guy you would want to fight in
the NFL he'd be up there just from sheer
the way he looks
got some of these deal I'm and we play
these days like terrell suggs even
though he's old he's like I told mine I
he played him a couple weeks ago I was
like you're like the only guy I play
ever that's older than me and you know
he just seems like he'd be a handful in
a fight there's a lot of those a lot of
those guys and they all play like d-line
it's and they're all fast too like it's
a different world even in the 13 years
that I came in every every year when I
was a rookie first year player you know
each maybe a team had won maybe every
other game there was one every team now
has three or four guys up front on
defense they're like how are we gonna
block these guys didn't you almost get
traded to the Patriots I did and is that
prior to them drafting Gronk yep it was
contingent on that also if they didn't
get Gronk yep so it's I've don't know if
I often I've told the story I've told it
a few times so I got called in to Jerry
Angelo's office so this would have been
going into the to thousands of been the
2010 offseason with the Bears with the
Bears we had we had brought in Mike
Martz we had a little offensive change
brought in some new coaches before that
draft so that was Gronk's draft I had
known Gronk a little but we have the
same agent we were training together
down in Miami and Jeri Angela brought me
into his office and he's like hey I'm
just gonna
honest with you we have a trade in place
with you contingent on how the draught
falls tomorrow night and come to later
find out through some guys that I knew
in the organization it was with the
Patriots and it was them assuming that
he was going to be taken in the first
round that year the Patriots had three
second-round draft picks and they were
gonna trade one of those for me if Gronk
was already taken in the first round he
fell to the second round
they took him with their second round
pick called the belcheck called back the
Bears said we're gonna take Gronkowski
with our second-round pick and the trade
is now off and then then they call me
back in they said all right we
entertained that trade you're gonna play
for us this year played for them in 2010
and then they ended up trading me 2011
you ever wonder what would have happened
if he played with the paint you know
there's a lot of you know what ifs and
all that but um I wouldn't trade being
character I wouldn't trade being traded
to Carolina for anything I mean what
that was for like personally and then of
course what that's been for my career
and and with the success we've had going
to a team that was the worst team in the
league in 2010 yeah - then you know
culminate to the Super Bowl appearance
in 15 you know four or five playoff
appearances we really were able to kind
of ride this thing cam being a big part
Ron and there's a few of us there from
that first 2011 season we've been
through a lot and the city of Carolina
the City of Charlotte has been awesome
to our family how often do you look at
Christian McCaffrey and go how the hell
is that guy like he's special I mean you
and I know that we look at him and he
looks like he would be you know some kid
next door would be you know a paper
route yeah he bulked up is he a killer
like a he's unbelievable he's off seen
his offseason training the way he takes
care of his body and you notice from the
first I mean we all watched him in
college and he was special and dynamic
but we've all seen guys in college that
are super prolific struggle to make that
transition to the NFL but when we first
met him as a rookie in offseason
workouts just talking to him he was wise
well beyond his years there's not a lot
of guys that came into league with his
understanding of all the other stuff the
training taking care of his body the
nutrition his dad helped out yeah it
doesn't it doesn't hurt that he grew up
in an NFL locker room right now
and we joke he's got a guy for
everything he's got a nutritionist guy
he as a training guy he has a speed guy
he has a guy for everything and the
results speak for themselves he's he's
just incredibly dynamic he's strong he's
a lot stronger than you would think I
mean he is put together he's a strong
dude he's fast he can handle such a
volume which is kind of not the norm and
NFL these days it's always kind of a
shared backfield but he doesn't want to
share it he wants every rep I know
you'll have to get out here but I want
to let you talk about smart water
alkaline your partnership that you have
with those guys you know obviously you
know how we feel about our community
back in Charlotte we're very involved at
the Children's Hospital after everything
our son went through there so we do a
lot of work in the in the community and
my wife and I are actually throwing our
first annual fit fest the hardest yard
fit fest on Monday we get back off the
bye week and smart smart water alkaline
is a huge partner of ours being there to
help put this event on keep our keep all
of our attendees hydrated and keep them
going it's gonna be a great event we're
gonna raise a lot of money for the
Children's Hospital and they've been a
great partner of ours it's always great
to see and I wish you well if I can help
you in any way when you make that
transition
thanks so much the things to do and not
do when you get into this goofy business
but good luck on Sunday with the Giants
and the Cardinals game appreciate it
thanks for having me Greg Olson Panthers
tight in four more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]